all right so viva mexico we are
celebrating mexican independence day a
day early yeah jc fernandez is live at
husson's candida inside mandalay bay
with some great ways to enjoy the
holiday hey jc
hey mercedes and rocky we are getting
ready to celebrate of course september
16th 1810 that's when mexico started the
fight for their independence and we are
starting the celebration today at hu
songs this is heidi with husongs we've
got the rock and roll mariachi band
we'll get to them in a second because
they are unbelievable but heidi i think
we need to kind of toast mexicans
independence and you need a good
margarita to do that what do you have
for us so we have the original margarita
because who songs mexican cantina
invented it in 1941. so we're going to
have an original margarita
and what goes into the original
margarita put some lime juice on top of
that so this is a salt we salt the glass
first
okay we take some ice get some ice in
there there's only fresh ingredients
there's no mixes in here
how many different margaritas do you
guys have you have a location in
summerlin how many days do you like this
location well we have many margaritas
because we add mixers to it if you want
like mango or raspberry
but this is this is the original so what
we do here is we take our tequila get
the tequila going
forever traditional but okay about a
minute to 30 here let's add some tequila
into your margarita
a little double shot you guys having fun
back here celebrating husson's yes he
got some fresh said i didn't want to be
on tv no i'm kidding you guys are doing
good fresh lime fresh lime we got our
triple set triple sec
mix it all up in there and our fresh
agave
this is how you make the perfect
margarita there's no other way to make a
margarita shake down heidi you got to
shake it ready
it's perfect it's ready to go now
what i love too here at whose songs you
guys always have specials any special
for tomorrow so today we have our siete
maris which is the seven seas
traditional mexican dish and we have our
traditional torta and coming up here a
little bit we're really gonna break down
these dishes and talk about some
traditional mexican dishes that you guys
have outside of these two amazing ones
absolutely the rock and roll mariachi
band they can play anything mariachi
style now i love journey can you give me
some journey absolutely dear journey
they'll play us out the rock and roll
mariachi band and who songs celebrating
mexican independence
[Music]
your eyes next time
yes okay
that's beautiful thank you so much jc we
will check in with you later in the show